[Music]
it's gonna be a hot one in los angeles
so it's on the agenda today
my eyes are closed
like every day
what are you doing in my room
hunter packs
ah
vampire honey is a business cut next and
cash your checks
[Music]
well things have changed since you got
your ass kicked out the union
if i don't come up with 10k my wife and
my daughter are going to move to florida
hi dad you're late again
and the union is the only place that
could give me that kind of money
your record is chock full of incidents
but he's a new man one last chance this
is your final warning
vampires just trying to kill me and now
i just pissed my favorite [ __ ] only
everybody pisses himself the first huh
really yeah do you no i no no i didn't
but listen you did
you know what i see when i see a vamp
big old dollar sign
[Music]
vampires they're amongst us
and all they are is murderers
it's not eclipse new moon breaking dawn
point one it ain't like that all right
why do you know the names to all the
specific twilight films and what's your
gripe with breaking dawn part two it's
the exciting conclusion of the whole
twilight saga
welcome to the day shift [ __ ]
[Music]
works
time case
murder
every
[Music]
[Music]
you